there are lots of problems around the
world that require public sector
intervention required owners and
governments to provide resources to
address you know whether it's public
health goals whether it's education
goals but one of the things that the
foundation is really excited about is to
how to leverage the private sector and
the reason that we're really excited
about that is that we know that markets
don't currently work well for the poor
but we really believe that markets can
be made to work well for the poor so if
you think about it you know why don't
markets work well for the poor well they
don't work well because first of all the
poor don't have any money which means
they're low margin they're not a
particularly attractive market you know
the poor weather there in inner cities
in the US or whether they're in you know
a rural area of Africa they have some of
the most challenging distribution
channels which means for a company it's
really hard to to even get to them the
transaction costs of reaching the poor
are really are higher and worth more
than the poor as a customer they live in
some of the most difficult markets in
the world you know just from a risk
perspective so a lot of companies are
like I you know I don't understand these
markets I don't understand the risks
they don't have a lot of information
about them so where is you know you can
go and get my new detail on consumers in
the US you don't even know what these
consumers look like what you know what
are the basic information about these
markets and lastly a lot of the
procurement a lot of the buying of goods
and services for the poor is done
through governments and is done through
donor agencies and it's hard for
companies to it's hard for those two
worlds to talk together and work
effectively together so it's really not
surprising that most companies don't
focus on the poor it's a tough market at
the same time the foundation knows that
if we're going to solve the problems
that we're trying to solve and it's not
just for the foundation it's for all of
us if we're going to try to solve these
problems we've got to tap into the
creativity and the capability and
you know the innovation potential of the
private sector you know the private
sector brings skills that we absolutely
need it brings you know scale
manufacturing and an understanding of
how to optimize manufacturing to drive
down costs it brings innovative capacity
so you know some of them the greatest
innovations that we've had in the world
have come out of the private sector it
attracts extraordinary talent so you
know the most talented people the most
creative people are most often going
into two companies these dates so if we
want to solve the problems that we're
trying to solve we've got to figure out
how do we tap into that extraordinary
capability of the private sector so what
we're thinking about doing is how do we
pull those partnerships together how do
we get a bunch of different types of
organizations that haven't talked to
each other together to say hey markets
don't work well for the poor for good
reasons private sector brings
extraordinary capability to solving
those problems how do we bring those two
things together for the foundation we
think about it in a number of different
ways we think about how do we dearest
how do we work with private sector
partners to de-risk their interests and
their capital allocation toward these
markets and we can use our investment
tools to do that we can use you know
whether it's a guarantee daddy risk a
market or whether it's providing equity
investments you know to go into a new
opportunity we can think about using our
capital to de-risk the other thing that
that's really important is getting
people to talk to each other so you know
the the the donor markets the government
markets are a big opportunity for
companies you know we've got companies
like you know all of the big
pharmaceutical companies providing
vaccines and providing commodities and
providing different types of products
into these markets they're big markets
but the donor community the the
procurement processes within governments
and donors don't always talk well do
these companies so one of the things
that we're doing is really thinking
about
how do we catalyze those
multi-stakeholder discussions where we
can bring together foundations we can
bring together governments we can bring
together the private sector such that
those two cultures can you know that can
begin to talk to each other and figure
out how do they use the different
resources to really tackle these big
social problems in a way that has the
potential to open up these markets for
these companies and solve problems for
for the people that are really focused
on the social problems